Helpsters, our goal is to help Heart get back to us.
Any ideas, huh?
Wait.
If I remember correctly, the rooms in our shop move around.
Oh yeah, we should stop them.
Done.
OK, so now that's taken care of, what do we do, huh?
First, we'll need a map of the shop.
Oh yes, yes we do, so that is job one.
[BELL] Get a map of the shop.
Next, we should find Heart on the map.
Yeah we should, so that'll be job two,
[BELL] figure out where Heart is on the map.
Then we need to find ourselves, and I
mean on a map, none of this backpacking through Europe
after graduation business.
Huh?
Never mind.
OK, well job three, [BELL] figure out
where we are on the map.
Yes.
And once we do all that, then the last, [BELL]
tell Heart how to get from there to here.
So job one, get a map of the shop.
Let's do it.
Oh, I have a map on this tablet that
shows where the rooms stop.
Look.
Oh, great.
Perfect
Fantastic.
Get a map of the shop, [BELL] check.
One job done.
Three more to go.
Yeah.
There's the horn room.
Find out where Heart is on the map, [BELL] check.
And here we are at the counter where the customers sit.
Figure out where we are, [BELL] check.
Three jobs done.
One more to go.
Look at us getting it done here.
OK.
So, uh Heart is there,
Mm-hmm.
And we are here.
Yeah.
I think I see a path.
[SQUEAKER] That is the best one.
Heart, I found a way back.
I'm going to give you commands, OK, ready?
Ready, Commander Cody.
All right.
First, open the door.
I am opening the door.
[DOOR OPENING]
Next, walk forward through the room.
Then open the other door.
I am walking forward and opening the other door.
All right.
Then walk forward again.
I am walking forward again.
[VIDEO GAME SOUNDS]
Great.
Cody, you did it.
Heart is in the kitchen, right here.
[DOOR OPENING] It's empty.
Where's Heart?
Heart, where are you?
I am in the clouds.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What?
Hang on, Heart.
You're up in the sky?
No, it is a room filled with clouds,
which is very beautiful.
There's the cloud room, right here.
But, how'd Heart get there?
I see what happened.
Heart went forward through two doors just like you said,
but instead of Heart going this way, Heart went that way.
Oh, I am so sorry, Heart.
I should have been clearer with my instructions.
There's more than one door in each room,
and we need to make sure you're going in the right direction.
How about we tell Heart which room to go in next?
Oh that's a great idea, Buddy bud.
No, I see a different path to get Heart back to us.
Look here.
Heart should go this way.
Heart.
Open the door to the stinky cheese room.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[DOOR OPENING]
The stinky-- bleh!
The stinky cheese room.
Excellent.
Now walk forward through the stinky cheese room.
No.
What do you mean no?
It is too stinky.
Well I know that it's stinky.
It's the stinky cheese room.
I will not go that way.
Thank you for your time.
But, but that is the path.
The path is the path is the path is the path.
Oh frumplekins.
No, Mr. Primm I see another way.
All right, Heart, listen to me and listen good.
I know you've been through a lot today.
Not really.
It's been pretty nice actually.
Oh, OK.
I forgot what I was doing.
Helping Heart get back.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
OK.
All right, first find the blue room and walk forward into it.
[VIDEO GAME SOUNDS]
I am in the blue room.
I found it on my first try.
Oh, great.
Next command, find the glow-in-the-dark room and walk
forward into that.
[VIDEO GAME SOUNDS]
OK I am in the glow-in-the-dark room.
Next command, find the door to the jungle room
and walk forward into it.
OK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[DOOR OPENING]
[JUNGLE SOUNDS]
I am in the jungle room.
Last command, walk forward through the jungle room
and open the door.
[JUNGLE SOUNDS]
[DOOR OPENING]
Helpsters!
Heart!
Oh, Heart.